- [Instructor] Hello readers.
Today let us talk about drama.
Enter stage right and let us
tread the boards together.
Drama, also known as theater or plays,
is a specialized kind of story
that is meant to be performed.
If you've ever seen a movie,
a television show or a play,
or if you've ever heard a play
on the radio or through a podcast,
you've experienced the
magic of the dramatic arts.
Writing a drama is different
than writing a poem or story.
And that means that reading
one is different, too.
So I'm gonna show you
part of a short drama
on the Khan Academy website
in order to go through
the parts of a play.
Okay, so here we have
the title of the piece,
My Unusual Aunt.
But it's followed by something
you maybe haven't seen before
which is the Cast of Characters.
This tells us who's in the play,
a 12 year old named Isabella,
and her aunt Yasmin.
Now these are the characters
the actors will be
performing in the drama.
There may be other people referenced.
Like for example in this piece
Isabella refers to her Dad
being asleep in Scene Two.
But he never shows up on stage.
A play is decided into scenes,
which you can think of
like chapters in a book.
Scenes are sections of a drama
that are separated by time or location.
Scene One takes place
in the evening outside.
Scene Two takes place at
Isabella's house some time later.
How do we know that?
The setting and stage directions.
So this italic slanty
text here in the brackets
tells us where the scene
is set in time and space.
It says Evening: Isabella
is walking her dog Stanley.
A bat dives down.
The name Isabella is
in all capital letters
to make sure the actor
playing Isabella notices.
And from this we know several things.
Isabella is in this scene, she's outside,
she's walking her dog, and it's nighttime.
So if this were a stage play,
we'd maybe see a set that looks
like Isabella's neighborhood.
She's walking the dogs, maybe we'd see
a little bit of sidewalk
or a fire hydrant.
There's more italics in this bit,
and it what are called stage directions.
An actor wouldn't read this
aloud during a performance.
Instead, stage directions tell the team
putting a drama together
what is happening on stage.
So a bat dives down.
That's gonna be a puppet or a prop
operated by a puppeteer or a stage hand.
And then we have this line of dialogue
spoken by Isabella reacting to the bat.
Ugh, since when do we have
bats in the neighborhood?
C'mon Stanley, let's run home.
So characters have lines.
The character name indicates
which character is speaking.
Sometimes you'll have a stage direction
just before a line of dialogue,
as we can see in Scene Two.
And Yasmin points to a giant
trunk before she talks,
but the actor playing her wouldn't say
pointing at giant trunk aloud.
That's a physical action
the script is asking her to perform.
These are the basic
components of a stage play.
The characters and their descriptions,
the way the play is divided into scenes,
the stage directions that tell actors
and others what to do,
and the lines of dialogue that
actors have to deliver aloud.
These are the building blocks of a play.
And now that you know that,
you know just enough to be dangerous.
Go write a play!
Tell it I sent you.
You can learn anything, David out.